es ist dein Patienten Albtraum Brand im
Krankenhaus in Rumänien schon fast
traurige Rutsch in 11kg Brände erlebt
das Land innerhalb eines Jahres über 30
Menschen sterben meist covid Patienten
Anfang November brennt es sind Projekt
zwei Menschen starben ein Funke und die
covid Station steht in Flammen
die Krankenschwester wollte ein Bett
verschieben um an einer Steckdose zu
kommen und da ging es los in Sekunden
es ist kein Zufall es hat System in
Rumänien der Pandemie gibt hier eine
Ärztin zu der
Hauptgrund ist die Sauerstofftherapie
die Sauerstoffkonzentration in der Luft
Raluca Berta hatte einen Arzt Shop in
Norwegen sie kehrte mit der Familie
zurück um in der Heimat etwas zu Ende
die Gehälter hier sein nicht mehr das
Hauptproblem sagt sie es ist das
Gesundheitssystem gell da die
verschwinden schlechte Ausstattung in
den Krankenhäusern immer weniger
Personal
alle 4 Stunden verlässt ein Arzt
Rumänien
sie hat Angst
ich wünschte wir hätten einen Apparat
der Mist ob zu viel freier Sauerstoff in
der Luft ist damit wir hier sicher sein
können
es gibt nicht nur Brandgefahr das
Material ist alt die Gebäude schimmelig
das Gesundheitsministerium reagiert
nicht auf unsere Fragen dazu
diese Bilder machte Emanuel uruguayo der
Abgeordnete darf Kliniken inspizieren
wird aber trotzdem dabei immer wieder
rausgeschmissen
die meisten Krankenhäuser in Rumänien
sind in Gebäuden die älter sind als 100
Jahre die staatliche Verwaltung
investiert nichts denn seit 30 Jahren
sind sie damit beschäftigt das
Gesundheitssystem zu bestehen
reichlich Skandale und zu viele Tote
kennt das rumänische Gesundheitssystem
und
keiner übernimmt Verantwortung 4
Gesundheitsminister gab es in der
Pandemie 35 Minister in den letzten 30
Jahren gegen mehrere laufen
Korruptionsverfahren
die Pandemie verschärft das Misstrauen
wenig Betrieb an den Impfzentren die in
Frate liegt unter 40%
entsprechend überfüllt sind die
Krankenhäuser Mitte Oktober hatte
Rumänien die höchste Todesrate der EU
jetzt Gesundheitssystem Ende Carmen
Moscato und oana Gheorghiu bauen mit
ihrer NGO Leben geben das erste
Kinderkrankenhaus in Rumänien seit der
Wind
und in der Pandemie auch zwei
hochmoderne Intensivstationen Alters
ausschließlich mit Spenden
Carmen und oana
[Musik]
2 Jahre nach dem Tod der Tochter
keiner im Gesundheitssystem hat mich
unterstützt
[Musik]